clear to live it's live beware all
Network TV shows are coming back to life
in a strange new form it's called an
event miniseries 24 live another day
premieres on Mayfair Kiefer Sutherland
and crew were back for a dozen episodes
shouldn't they change the name from 24
to 12 meanwhile heroes will be reborn as
heroes reborn
it just got a 13 episode limited renewal
little air in 2015
okay seriously which of you sent letters
demanding because we need the network's
make all these partially reprieved
programs miniseries but a dozen or so
episodes since actually the length of a
full season on HBO or AMC maybe the
network's are finally catching wise to
the fact the 24 episodes per season it's
just too damn many when you've got to
fill out two dozen episodes bad things
happen
sorry aren't slowed down and meander
around top quality actors shy away from
signing on because of the time
commitment now I'm not sure we need to
see more shows brought back from the
dead
I can think of a lot of shows on TV that
would benefit from being boiled down to
a succinct event miniseries I actually
care who Red John was if the Mentalist
and fewer twists and turns and reversals
networks I demand that you give me less
what series would you like to see trim
down I myself could have done with 10 or
20 fewer episodes of lost let me know in
the comments and subscribe to the wire
channel